figure out who you are don't apologize
for who you are and then become even
greater than you naturally are at what
you are just can't explain to everybody
like clearer when you figure out who you
are and do all that you win if you're
great at painting paint and hire a
partner to be your salesperson most
painters want to be the salesman and
businessmen and women as well as the
painter and there's a problem 90% of
people that are great at painting are
artists and don't have the DNA to sell
and vice versa all my sales friends and
business friends that want to start all
these businesses around something
creative I have bad news for you Joel
you know you could be a great salesman
but your Pottery sucks and so
that's that so like and it's that's a
very funny analogy for the following
figure out who you are don't apologize
for who you are and then become even
greater than you naturally are at what
you
are